sur le csa oui parce que je trouve que
vous verrouillez beaucoup mais parfois
vous n'êtes pas sur le coup il ya un
truc qui me choque beaucoup c'est des
bandes annonces de films violents dire
que moi j'aime bien parfois comme tout
père de famille j'aime bien parfois
pouvoir laisser mon gosse devant la télé
quand ça m'arrange quelques minutes et à
des heures où on sait pas trop dangereux
et parfois il ya des bandes annonces et
venait à partir du moment où je vais
vous le dire ou le film a eu tel
signalétique et que bon ben on n'a pas à
ce moment là à dire quoi que ce soit sur
la bande mais vous avez raison les
bandes sont souvent pas comme tout ça et
comme d'autres comme tout pub un
raccourci violent mais moi je vais vous
dire une chose je n'aime pas ça comme je
n'aime pas non plus ceux qui font de
kiel qui sont qui sont pour la drogue
moi je suis tout à fait contre l'état
pour la légalisation je suis content et
je vais vous dire une chose qui arrive
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et d'amitié pour
vous le savez j'aime pas que dans vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabba niche qui est pas vrai le
caractérise et ses canons mais non moi
je vous dis raison président moi je suis
contre je suis content je suis content
que je dis que chacun festive dans son
coin mais dans une émission et notamment
une mission de service public on veut
pas faire la promo de sa brève qu'elle
attendait ce que j'ai dans tout le monde
peut aller au noir et si j'ai un
reproche à vous faire c'est celui
largement ben ali je vous le dis comme
ça entre nous
[Musique]